I suppose that wasn't too difficult for you.
PTAS clearly is the most powerful approximate ability,
because with PTAS you can get any constant factor approximation that you want.
It is the smallest bubble in here.
Then we have the constant factor algorithms. So these here.
Then finally we have all of those problems for which there's
neither a constant-factor algorithm nor a PTAS up here.
We already briefly mentioned that any Las Vegas algorithm can be turned into
a Monte Carlo algorithm, and for that reason the complexity class of all problems
for which there are Monte Carlo randomized algorithms, contains the complexity class
of all problems for which there are Las Vegas algorithms.